scar is one of disney's most memorable
villains but the 2019 lion king movie
has changed some crucial details about
the evil lions origins and story
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm explaining the new secret
history of scar that's revealed in the
lion king remake
plus i'll tell you how the new movie
addresses a long-standing fan theory
that scar and mufasa aren't actually
brothers
some spoilers ahead so take care if you
haven't seen it yet
don't forget my giveaway is running so
be sure to subscribe and let me know
your thoughts about scar for a chance to
win
the origin of scar's name and how he
received the wound on his eye were never
addressed in the classic movie
however there's a vital addition to the
remakes version of the following scene
perhaps you shouldn't turn your back on
me
is that a challenge temper temper
i wouldn't dream of challenging you in
the 2019 version
scar says i wouldn't dream of
challenging you
again meaning that there's already been
a confrontation between the two lions in
the past
and i think the new film hints that it
was during this previous challenge that
mufasa gave scar the signature wound
across his left eye
for example in the reworked story when
mufasa begs his brother for help during
the stampede
scar viciously slashes him across the
eye which sends mufasa plunging to his
death in the gorge below
this is a change to the traditional
animation where scar flings mufasa off
the cliff
by adding the face slash in the remake
it suggests that the villainous line is
taking revenge in kind for the scar
mufasa gave him
now what's also interesting about this
change is that it seems to invalidate
the backstory given to scar in a book
series that was a spin-off from the
classic film
the first story of that series a tale of
two brothers recounted that scar was
originally called taka and that he
changed his name to scar
after getting into a scrape with a
buffalo that slashed him across the eye
with his horns
although that book series was authorised
by disney it's not entirely clear
whether it's ever been canon as elements
from it don't fit with the animated lion
king sequel
either way the 2019 movie suggests a
brand new origin viscar's signature
wound
another change in the remake that's
quite likely related to that fateful
challenge between scar and mufasa
is scar's new backstory with sarabi who
was mufasa's queen of the pride lands
in the new movie a subplot involving
romantic jealousy has been added to
scar's origins
and the first hint at that comes at the
beginning of the new story
when scar says to mufasa and zazu as you
know
i have tremendous respect for the queen
in fact in the novelization of the new
lion king film when scar says that line
it triggers an intense anger in mufasa
this indicates that mufasa and skull's
rivalry over sarabi
has been stewing for some time and it
also reveals that as well as wanting to
rule the pride lands there was an
additional motive behind scars personal
feud with mufasa
later after scar takes over as king
sarabi accuses him of over
hunting at which point he reveals long
ago you chose mufasa over me
but now there is a new king with mufasa
gone scar now requests that she join him
as queen that new dialogue reminds me of
a deleted scene from the 1994 movie
where scar was wondering why his
subjects don't look up to him like they
did his brother
i'm sick to death of him what did he
have that i don't have
adoring subjects respect of your species
a loving family a devoted queen
shall i go on the fire in the remake
scar realizes he's unloved by the rest
of the pride and believes that if he can
make sarabi his partner then he'll gain
the respect
she has from the other lions yes i need
a queen she would rule by my side we'll
have cubs
little scars running all over the place
in the deleted scene from 1994
scar actually proposes to nala rather
than sarabi
like simba's mother nala also refused
and scar responded by threatening her
you know you really have no choice one
way or another
i always get what i want
either be my queen or be forever
banished from the pride lands
scars creepy threats in the animated
movie were also going to be one of the
reasons that nala decided to leave pride
rock to look for help
and there's another nod to that deleted
scene in a brand new scene for nala in
the remake where she has to sneak around
scar on the hyenas before she can get
away another change to scar's back story
is that in the new version he doesn't
team up with the hyenas before his visit
to the elephant graveyard
now when scar arrives it's clear there
isn't an alliance between them yet
as they even threaten to eat him this is
quite different to the first movie where
the hyenas are obviously unfamiliar
terms with scar
oh scars just you you were afraid it was
somebody
important i mean you're one of us i mean
you're our pal he even brings them fresh
meat to eat
i don't think you really deserve this i
practically gift clap those cubs for you
given scar's lack of familiarity with
the hyenas and the cg reboot
it seems like his plan to send simba to
the elephant graveyard wasn't something
pre-arranged with them
he was simply hoping to take advantage
of the hyenas natural behavior and that
they'd kill and eat the young cub of
their own accord
there's an interesting change to how
scar guilt trips simba about mufasa's
death in the remake
this time scar takes simba into the
gorge specifically
under the pretext that the little cub
needs to practice his roar
this gorge is where all lions come to
find their roar
watch this you'll get it simba just
takes time
that would be so proud won't he it's a
gift he'll never forget
by contrast in the 1994 classic scar
tells simba to wait there for a
marvelous surprise from his father
what is it if i told you it wouldn't be
a surprise now would it and rather
deviously only mentions practicing as
raw as a throwaway line in passing
and just between us you might want to
work on that little roar of yours
however in the new movie scar
deliberately and clearly links simba's
raw with his father
even mufasa came here when he was your
age
refused to leave until his roar could be
heard
above the rim which firmly plants the
seed in the young lion's mind that
practicing is raw
led to his dad's death that makes simba
feel even guiltier later when he thinks
his father died trying to save him
and when scar arrives to find the poor
little cub grieving over his dead father
in the remake the villain twists the
knife even further with some brand new
lines not in the animated movie
scar says to simba your father had such
hopes for you
gave you so many chances and this is how
you repay him
then after asking the young cub what
will your mother think
in the new version scar also tells simba
that he's a son who caused his father's
death and a boy who killed a king
something that's confused lion king fans
for many years is a theory that
claims scar and mufasa might not really
be brothers
i think the new movie gives its own
answer to that question but just before
we get into that we need to review the
evidence for why scar and mufasa might
not be related by blood
the moment from the 1994 film used to
support that theory is when scar
compares his intellectual and physical
capabilities with mufasa's
as far as brains go i got the lion's
share but when it comes to brute
strength i'm afraid i'm at the shallow
end of the gene pool
the theory claims that what scar's
really saying is that he and mufasa
aren't
genetically related when it comes to the
theory there have been some conflicting
attempts by the animations filmmakers to
clarify
the situation in a 2017 interview with
hello giggles
producer don han said while making the
movie we talked about the fact that it
was very likely scar and mufasa would
not
have both the same parents occasionally
there are prides that do have two male
lions but they're not equals
one line will always kind of be off in
the shadows we were trying to use those
animal truths to underpin the story
so we sort of figured scar mufasa
couldn't really be from the same gene
pool
but while han heavily implied skara
mufasa weren't brothers
to add to the confusion a couple of
weeks later the lion king's director rob
minkoff told screen junkies the exact
opposite saying that he wanted to clear
up that scar mufasa were in fact
brothers
despite all that the 2019 movie seems to
take a few steps to provide more clarity
first of all the shallow end of the gene
pool line from scar has been replaced
and he now says
when it comes to brute strength i'm
afraid my big brother will always rule
so the original line which seemed to
trigger the theory has been scrapped
and substituted with scar specifically
calling mufasa his big brother
on top of that there's another change at
the end of the new film
just after scar confesses december that
he killed mufasa
a new line has been added where simba
asks him your own brother
how could you the emphasis on this new
line implies that simba is completely
outraged because he views scar's murder
of mufasa as even more heinous as the
two lines were related
disney also used the opportunity of
remaking the lion king to fix a number
of other mistakes and confusing moments
in the classic movie
you can learn all about those in my
other video tap the screen to watch that
or click the link in the video
description
now what do you think about the new scar
and the changes to the villain story
let me know in the comments below and
subscribe to enter my lion king giveaway
next tap left for my full comparison of
the two lion king movies
or tap right for another video you're
sure to like and if you enjoyed this a
like and a share are always hugely
appreciated
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupika movie lovers